5 powerful foods to boost your immunity
Ginger contains powerful
anti-inflammatory and antioxidant agents
that can help to reduce inflammation and
boost the production of white blood
cells Ginger enhances the activity of
natural killer cells which can help your
body to fight off infection more
effectively garlic has antiviral and
antibacterial properties that can help
to fight off infection it is also a good
source of vitamin C and B6 as well as
minerals such as selenium and manganese
all of which are essential for a healthy
immune system turmeric contains curcumin
a compound with powerful
anti-inflammatory and antioxidant
effects it also boosts the production of
white blood cells and enhances the
activity of natural killer cells
sunflower seeds are a good source of
vitamin E and zinc which help to protect
cells from damage and boost the
production of white blood cells
blueberries are a good source of
antioxidants including vitamin C and
anthocyanins which can help protect
cells from damage by free radicals
remember to stay healthy and stay
curious